here we have a gen Z or a Zoomer by the
name of cat
complaining about how much harder it is
for young people today than it was for
her parents and her grandparents
generation I think that if you if you
College you deserve to be able to make
enough to live comfortably I'm going to
stop you right there I think if you
don't go to college you should be able
to make enough to live comfortably
regardless your major regardless if you
chose to go to college or not you
deserve to live comfortably so anyone
who says that your path to success
should have looked differently they're
probably just not able to conceptualize
the reality of today's job market and
the reality of how much it costs to go
to school nowadays okay we were doing so
well but then the Gen zeitis kicked in
and she started babbling about what she
deserves I honestly don't know what a
statement like I deserve to live
comfortably means to deserve something
is to earn it it's to be worthy of it
are we all worthy of a comfortable life
have we earned it just by simply
existing